(bouncy chiming music)
- [Narrator] This is Koda, a
three-year-old African cheetah.
Critically endangered, less
than 8,000 remain in the wild.
The African cheetah is built for speed.
It's the world's fastest land animal,
clocking zero to 60 miles per
hour in a mere 3.4 seconds.
Long and lean with a flexible spine,
they use their tail as a rudder,
steering when running after prey.
They stalk their prey under the bright sun
of the African Savanna.
The tear marks that run across their face
help reflect the glare of the
sun much like football players
apply paint beneath
their eyes before a game.
They once roamed across all of Africa,
but today are found in less than a quarter
of their historic range.
Habitat loss, poaching, and loss of prey
are all threats to this beautiful cat.
This is the African cheetah.